in a deeply unpredictable leadership
race
some routine the cabinet gathering for
its weekly meeting good morning but the
real action right now is outside downing
street as politicians focus on who to
put back inside number 10. uniting
around one leader there are plenty of
excellent secretary of state who are you
going to back
my decision
one decision was made today which
contenders were through to the second
round three withdrawing without the
numbers but eight still in the race
those eight will go to the first round
uh ballot tomorrow between 1 30 and 3 30
was the result announced uh as soon as
we can please welcome rishi sunak
ready for that ballot with a big cabinet
beast back in him the former chancellor
rashi sunak leading in this race but
keen as well not to put too much
distance between himself and his former
boss i want to talk
about boris johnson i will have no part
in a rewriting of history that seeks to
demonize boris wanting to align with his
foe while also setting himself apart
from other contenders when it comes to
tax policy we need a return to
traditional conservative economic values
and that means
honesty and responsibility
not fairy tales it is not credible to
promise lots more spending and lower
taxes but it is credible to question
this candidate over wider issues you've
just stood here and said boris johnson's
a remarkable person you don't want
history to demonize him the party's just
ousted him on the basis of conduct
probity and causing division
and here you are you have a police fine
over partygate and there have been
questions too
over your very wealthy family
avoiding paying millions of pounds in
tax so i put it to you
that you're not a clean start that you
might be more of the same i think it's
important that we do whoever wins this
election does restore trust because
trust has been broken and we need to
rebuild all of that with the country
what has really humbled me and given me
an enormous amount of encouragement is
the breadth of support from people
from
from it's from all wings of the party
it's from all regions of the party and
that's why i believe i'm best placed to
bring the party back together
but just as mr sunak was launching his
bid support from the johnson wing of the
party coalescing behind foreign
secretary liz trust the candidate that
we select and uh for me it's as liz who
i'm going to back
will continue with those manifesto
promises and will continue to deliver
for the government
and for the conservative party but you
don't like rishi sonak do you
this a man keen to stop rishi sunak in
his tracks i think mr tsunak is an
extremely personable man but i think he
was not running the economy world and
i've made this clear and you think he
betrayed your
your
prime minister the person that you have
consistently supported
i think it's very interesting that
somebody should start
um a campaign according to reports in
december of last year
away from the big beasts in the fight
this back bench are keen to break from
the past we need a clean start
for me that is much more than just a
slogan or a catchphrase it summarizes
our advance orders
for the next decade
it allows us to move forward together a
fresh optimistic enthusiastic
confident post-brexit
and ready to seize the moment as is this
ex-minister on the right of the party
and through to the next round we have
overburdened our economy there is too
much unproductive public spending
consuming taxpayers harder and money and
there are too many well-meaning
regulations slowing growth and clogging
up the arteries of the economy
a moment of calm tonight after another
frenetic day in westminster and this
race set to get more fraught still as
the sonic campaign and the one to stop
him gathers pace beth rigby sky news
westminster